let's go next to Brandon from Colorado
Brandon you were on the air
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
perfectly
great so my mom is heavily invested into
the anti-vaxx uh scene and I'm sent a
lot of videos all the time and I've been
watching them and clearly there's an
underground uh of anti-vaxx communities
and they do not agree on facts and
they're sort of Trapped in their Echo
chamber they think what they're doing is
right and so on
and
I do not think that the uh covid
conferences like we heard this weekend
um are not really going to cut it for
these people who are
um spreading this information and so I'm
thinking what I would be interested to
see with the uh the people that they
think are lying so medical experts
doctors whatever uh personally confront
them to show them the evidence and
hopefully talk through with them to come
to realization of the truth to actually
get on the page with the facts and I'm
wondering do you think this would even
be possible or people are considering
this uh could this be a valid tactic to
at least engage with this uh very
serious part of uh anti-vaccine
misinformation so first of all I mean on
a very practical level
there's not enough doctors and public
health experts to do one-on-one
confrontations with anti-vaxxers to
convince them to change their mind so so
on a practical level I think it's very
difficult the other thing is
um oftentimes when people are presented
with facts and told what you believe is
wrong here are the facts it doesn't
convince them it actually makes them
further kind of plant their feet in the
sand and not move from where they are
what we do know is that the people that
are already in one's community so if Dr
fauci shows up at your mom's house
she'll probably be like this guy's a
liar I over this I'm not going to
believe this guy but if your Mom's
doctor were who presumably she trusts
says you need to get the vaccine it's
really important I've gotten it my
patients have gotten it that does seem
to have a real impact so I think it's
less about bringing in experts from
outside people's lives to tell them
you're wrong it's more about creating
conversations with the people already in
your community so for some people it's
it's their Pastor which is so disturbing
why when we see these pastors like Greg
Locke who we covered earlier this week
say do not get vaccinated to their
churches a lot of people if their Pastor
said get vaccinated they would do it
same thing goes for local Physicians and
that type of thing so I think that
there's a lot to what you're saying in
terms of people need to hear from their
local doctor whoever people they trust
go and get vaccinated if you sit Dr
fauci in front of your mom I don't think
it convinces her
do you think that would be sort of the
same case because what I'm saying is to
uh to to confront that like the host of
these shows on bit shoot or whatever who
have had their shows for so long
basically it's sort of the same thought
as uh what did you say [ __ ] [ __ ] what
what was that bit shoot
Rumble you know those underground
YouTube pieces I mean but I I mean
basically the same idea as what if we
got the biggest uh you know Flat Earth
personalities and oh I see what you're
saying I see what you're saying so if
there's some really big anti-vaxx person
with a big audience and they get just
schooled and made to look like idiots
but yeah that could have an impact that
could have an impact that I don't deny
that that's an interesting idea
okay well thank you for uh free call
thank you all right Brandon from
Colorado uh I will call you again soon